dans cet hôpital de la proche banlieue
parisienne la cinquième vague exerce une
pression continue karimi a été admis il
ya trois jours et comme tous les
patients ici sauf un il n'est pas
vacciné est plein de remords délai si je
m'en sors bien
j'ai conservé tout le monde est abattu
parce que c'est comment il va qu'on
entend dans votre youtube
du complot
ce genre de regrets le personnel
soignant l'entend souvent assez pour
avouer à certain agacement et il nous
répond que en fait dès qu'ils sortent
ici mon sens vacciné mais j'ai envie de
leur dire déjà il faut sortir d'ici quoi
matin une augmentation en flèche des
nouvelles contaminations et la
propagation inédite variant micron la
france redouble ses efforts de
vaccination
il faut tout douze noms de clubs et
autres facteurs de passeports sanitaire
des plus de 65 ans n'est désormais plus
valide sans une troisième dose est
depuis aujourd'hui les enfants de 5 ans
et plus jugés vulnérables peuvent être
vaccinés
dans une demi douzaine de pays européens
dont l'italie l'allemagne et l'espagne
se sont tous les enfants de plus de 5
ans qui relève la manche au son des
encouragements enthousiastes de leurs
parents avec la promesse d'une sucrerie
après une petite piqûre
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que nous voyons
maintenant le nouveau variant micron à
l'horizon de la présidente de la
commission européenne on nous dit qu'à
la mi-janvier nous devrions nous
attendre à ce qu microns soit le nouveau
variant dominant en europe
d'un contexte l'italie a annoncé un
durcissement des conditions d'entrée sur
son territoire pour les voyageurs en
provenance de l'union européenne dès
jeudi la grande bretagne s'est peut être
retirée de l'union européenne il ya
bientôt un an et n'en est pas moins
frappés par cette cinquième vague au
contraire avec 78 1610 cas positifs
enregistrés en 24 heures du jamais vu
depuis le début de la pandémie en 2020
le premier ministre boris johnson parle
d'un raz-de-marée il souhaite que son
pays arrivent à vacciner un million de
personnes par jour s'ils sont très
nombreuses depuis 48 heures à patienter
pendant des heures pour obtenir une
troisième dose certaines des nouvelles
mesures anti qu'ovide comme le
télétravail obligatoire le port du
masque en intérieur et le passeport
sanitaires pour les grands événements
ont provoqué une rébellion sans
précédent au sein même de ses troupes
goldstone de pipeau je comprends le
sentiment des gens passaient ce qu'il
considère comme des atteintes à la
liberté a dit boris johnson et nous
avons essayé tout au long de cette
flambée me de maintenir la société de
maintenir nos vies s'est il défendu
celui qui dicte le rythme et les règles
c'est le virus dans une grande entrevue
bilan diffusé en soirée manuel macron
n'a pas exclu que la france elle aussi
adopté des mesures sanitaires plus
strictes ce qui pourrait être annoncé
dès vendredi
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris